وفد ايراني في الرياض لبحث اعاده فتح
السفاره
رغم عشرات القضايا ترامب يؤكد عدم انسحابه
من سباق الرئاسه
مخاوف في الصين بعد تسجيل اول وفاه
بانفلونزا الطيور
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا اخبارنا من السعوديه حيث وصل وفد
ايراني الى المملكه لاتخاذ الاجراءات
والترتيبات اللازمه لاعاده فتح السفاره
الايرانيه في الرياض والقنصليه الايرانيه
في جده اضافه الى بحث استئناف نشاط
الممثليه الايرانيه الدائمه في منظمه
تعاون الاسلامي وكان وفد فني سعودي قد زار
طهران يوم السبت الماضي لمناقشه اليات
اعاده فتح ممثليات المملكه في ايران وذلك
انفاذا لاتفاق البلدين مؤخرا على استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
مهما كان حجم القضايا والاتهامات فهذا لن
يمنعني من الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
بهذه الكلمات تعهد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب لانصاره في تجمع انتخابيين
بالعزم على خوض الانتخابات المقبله الذي
يواجه اربعا وثلاثين تهمه جنائيه في
نيويورك اكد امام انصاره بان الرئيس جو
بايدن غير مؤهل للترشح مره اخرى على حد
وصفه ولا شيء يمنع من الترشح حتى الادانه
في خبر اثار المخاوف الوبائيه مجددا اعلنت
الصين تسجيل اول حاله وفاه جراء الاصابه
بانفلونزا الطيور وفقا لما افادت به منظمه
الصحه العالميه الصحه العالميه قالت في
بيان ان المتوفي امراه تبلغ من العمر 56
عاما هي الحاله الثالثه التي تم كشف
اصابتها بانفلونزا الطيور اتش ثري ان 8
وهي نوع فرعي من انفلونزا الطيور فيما
اوسط السلطات الصحيه بالصين السكان بضروره
توخي الحذر والابلاغ عن اي حاله مشابهه
في عالم الرياضه صرحت دارسوتبي للمزادات
بان حذاء اسطوره الكره السله الامريكيه
مايكل جوردن الذي ارتداه في نهايه دوري
كره السله الامريكيه عام 98 تم بيعه مقابل
2.2 مليون دولار امريكي وبذلك يصبح اغلى
حذاء رياضي على الاطلاق هذا الحذاء هو من
نوع
وهي علامته الخاصه من شركه نايكي واكانت
المباراه الاخيره له عندما سجل جوردن 37
نقطه وقاد فريقه شيكاغو بولز الى اللقب
السادس بانتصاره على
يبدو ان تشات دخل على خط التقنيات
المساعده للمكفوفين هذه المره هذه المره
اذا شركه بي ماي ايز بدات بتفعيل تطبيق
الجوال للمكفوفين كاداه
وللمساعده المرئيه بشكل رقمي مدعومه من
التطبيق يمكن المكفوفين من التعرف على
الرموز الرقميه لكل شيء امامهم وتحويل
الصور الى نصوص ومن ثم الى صوت وبذلك يمكن
المكفوف من التعرف على ما يلمسه وذلك
بمساعده متطوعين يعززون قدره الذكاء
الاصطناعي لاداء هذه المهمه
[موسيقى]